four and two thirds innings of one run
ball his last timeout he makes his
fourth start of the year
field one that is a diving play by
franco at third it was hit
so hard the orioles are able to turn two
franco wide mouth starts at five four
three twin killing yeah i take my glove
off my hat off and give him a standing
ovation
i mean this ball rocket and geo rochelle
the yankee cleanup hitter
two and two chased and missed
arshello went up the ladder and cramer
gets a big
strikeout with two outs as torres left
at third
domingo you can see this will be his
first start on the season one and two
record
cedric mullins leaves off
[Music]
not only scooped into center field hicks
is there
one away so to be a 3-1
and the pitch is lined right to glabor
right into his glove he didn't move an
inch as they say he didn't move a muscle
so one two three go the birds we go to
the top of the second inning here's mike
ford fly ball left field
deep that ball is gone a home run into
the first row
caught by a yankee fan hit by a yankee
it's one nothing
bombers a really good swing he drives
this up and out over the plate a little
bit late but he went with the pitch
and he thinks it's got a chance and it
does
frazier three two swing and a miss yes
sir
it was a fastball that was up frazier
a strikeout victim kramer working from
the wind his pitch
and he goes to the cutter here and he
strikes out agashioka so
gave up the lead off home run but he
gets the next three
severino at home one on one out
did he make the play yes he did what a
play by higashiyoka
for the second out that is as good as it
gets
quickness get there slide
no margin for error and here's gleber
with two on and one out
that one is looped into center field
it's a base hit
lamehu will score the throw goes to
third staying at second is stanton it's
an rbi single for torres
he's two for two and the yankees lead
two nothing see the big curveball the
spikes grip
from dean cramer left it up that's
middle middle
claber even though he was a little bit
fooled he kept his hands back and was
able to still deserve it in the center
and get up get that run home
2-1 pitch driven deep to left field that
ball is gone
cia caught in a hat a three-run home run
it is
five nothing yankees middle and you talk
about wheel house
exactly where you'd ask for it if you
were a hitter orioles trying to get
their first hit here in the fourth
inning against domingo hermann
austin hayes is the number two hitter
tonight hayes on a one-two with the
chopper to second
mayhew charges it and the gold glove
second baseman makes the play here's
trey mancini
swing and a miss 95 miles an hour
mancini down on strikes
right on cue as well 95 miles an hour
and this is a quality strength this is
command
franco against her mom with two outs
knowing on bottom of the fourth he yanks
with a five-nothing lead
the pitch strike three right down the
pipe
right down broadway but they have the
bases loaded in one out
and here is aaron hicks
damage pitch coming up
high fly ball right field stewart
makes a catch tagging is stanton he'll
score without a throw
going to second is ford and he's in
there
and also tagging to third or shella so
heads up base running by four to sac fly
for hicks six
nothing hanks the bottom of the fifth
inning 108 severino
strike three severino down looking
i mean just a great setup nice and wide
the gloves right there
two way there is ryan mount castle
grounded backhanded by rochelle with a
long throw
and there's the first base hit for the
orioles nice pick
by geo really had no chance there just
getting just gloving that ball and then
getting it off
pretty impressive the bottom of the
sixth inning harman
has been obviously absolutely brilliant
down on strikes location location
location
spot on between pitcher and catcher
ground ball lemayo on the shortstop side
puts it away and
another one two three inning for domingo
hermond the bottom of the seventh the
yankees have a
six nothing lead here is michael franco
and the pitch strike three franco down
looking what a perfect pitch well
visually for a pitcher he loved the way
catcher set up
and higashioka is putting on a clinic
back there tonight two outs in the
seventh
so here's mount castle make it two in a
row one two
stride three drop the breaking ball he
liked that one pumped his fist
and that'll do with the seven the
orioles trail six nothing as we go into
the eighth
franco and severito over to the coach's
box
what's the catcher doing out in left
field shift
oh man shift duty right there and watch
this right here
i mean this is hustle though right there
he doesn't even hesitate
i think could get steamrolled pedro's
pretty big guy and i think michael
franco thought
once he sees the locomotive going down
the tracks
not getting in his way here's clint
frazier
high fly ball deep left did he get it
yes he did sia home run clint frazier
his first of the year
and the yankees lead seven nothing
aggressive approach we've seen clint
take a lot of pitches
middle end is in his wheelhouse look at
his eyes light up the minute it leaves
his bat
that split second after a hitter makes
contact that he he realizes
it's got a chance we go to the bottom of
the ninth inning
strike three hayes down looking
a breaking ball strike on the inside
corner michael
franco he's a right-hand hitter one on
one out
the o2
grabbed by wade there's one on to first
it's a double play and the yankees close
it out
they win this one seven nothing the big
three run home run by orschella gave
them breathing room they never look back
the yankees have won two in a row